peu
il ne faut pas trop se fier à ce nom il
est aussi trompeur que la chef de guerre
est jolie
d'ailleurs l'ancien nom de la porcherie
était plus éric ce qui signifie en bas
latin la jolie la noble
alors si vous voulez la porcherie en bas
des musées
évitez de prendre l'autre on
il ya longtemps qu'il ne s'arrête plus
ça va pas la tête il ya trois trains
express régionaux qui passent ici tous
les jours
pour faire un village prenez un paysage
et une église des commerces une mairie
un bureau de poste
mais cela ne suffit pas car pour faire
vivre le village
il faut surtout une école et des enfants
à la porcherie ne n'avais plus assez une
classe allait fermer
et pour éviter la mort lente de son
village monsieur le maire trouver un
remède original c'est par petites
annonces qu'ils recrutent à des familles
nombreuses de famille répondirent à
l'appel
et aujourd'hui il ya une vingtaine de
mandats en plus ils viennent d'en haut
du nord
le village est sauvé
[Applaudissements]
sos école en danger de disparition ça
c'était hier encore sur ces chaises
seulement 22 petites paires de fesses ça
une critique qui entraîne à court terme
une classe unique
donc un seul instituteur ici il y en a
encore deux le maire décide de réagir
et pour séduire d'éventuels nouveaux
ports chariot c'est le nom des habitants
de la porcherie offrent eux mêmes cet
appartement entièrement rénové au dessus
de l'école et sur pont et une famille
nombreuse vingt cinq ans il arpente
gérer les pannes se disent vous baser
ses mouches iphone 4g deux amis de 400
euros à condition que l'âge correspond
et puis un canapé elle a une famille
déjà tragédie c'est magnifique
le 21 janvier on voit monsieur arrivée
était 9h15 ou à monsieur à régler on s'y
attendait pas du tout et puis il s'est
présenté comme le maire de la porcherie
puis après un été surpris parce que vous
voyez un voyage issue qui débarque et
qui frappent à la porte
au départ on croyait que c'était un
représentant commun à beaucoup souvent
que c'est le cas guy je me présente je
suis maire de la porcherie
alors là ça commençait et travaillez
déjà de la tête en bas et parce que là
pour chéri quand même 500 et sa somme et
qu'on est le parrain
donc
aujourd'hui quelques années après leur
installation
sinon à retrouver un emploi
[Musique]
la dre faire de ici selon l'expression
de monsieur le maire et il ajoute je
reviens la nature qu'on ne verront pas
un châtaignier cherchell bref un chacun
cherche à obtenir il faut absolument
faire attention à certains cafés vous
pas qu'il y aura j'ai ouï mais peut-on
greffer le ch'timi sur un limousin loin
pour chariots et que deviennent les
racines je suis alors je suis né à
wattrelos à quelques kilomètres de
roubaix on nous sommes tous mais non à
tout quitter comme ça
bon on en avait marre de vivre déjà dans
con et et puis on a bâti bon si on vit
dans le fromage en haut ou en bas
c'était pareil je préfère avoir la
chaleur voir du beau temps - du soleil
parce que dire quand même une zahia
quand même reconnu par plus de soi et
que dans le nord déjà pour le temps des
gens j'ai dit bon qu'est ce qu'on voyait
de la fenêtre de vaud de votre maison et
je vous dire vous voyez la redoute vous
les envoyer en face c'est le nom de la
première fois que je lis immense et
qu'on était en marin il rentrait dans le
café que mes parents tenaient et puis il
est temps marc à une ou déjà qu'on voit
un marais ive temps d'un café
c'est impressionnant quand même je
travaillais dans une heure dans une
boîte on fasse c'était un café avec tous
les copains on allait voir toujours un
poids après le travail pire il y avait
une fille de la patronne faillite à
plusieurs elle m'a t'on bideau l'oeil
voilà c c'est une petite histoire vous
savez vous arriviez de vous moi
j'arrivais de pologne donc je suis
arrivé aux 68 au mois de juillet puisque
mes paroles sont issus des des micros et
polonais ou si j'avais pas à mon
français il fallait bien apprendre
quand même la langue qu'on sait sur les
habitués ne s'était pas trop facile mais
je savais qu'on veut quand on est
amoureux l'avancé sa torpeur
on me souvenir ce qui va rester ce que
j'ai j'ai perdu en face et j'ai quitté
c'est la pologne c'est par le nord parce
que c'est lorsque ça compte pas
tellement mais c'est surtout la pologne
aux internautes ils ont transité à
l'école et puis j'ai vu que michel
parler qu'elle arrive et que ces
enfants-là la porcherie
je me suis dit pourquoi pas moi comme
j'en avais marre l'avant de rester je
voulais tranquille partir et j'arrivais
ici
la première chose mon but c'était de ce
qui fut mon mari c'est malheureux à dire
mais ne travaillaient pas ils buvaient
salle est bon alors je voulais partir à
seulement créé des enfants j'en ai 4 et
premier mari que je divorce et ce qu'ils
buvaient au sipi qui était méchant et
j'en ai six savais que mon deuxième mari
lui aussi travaillé pas c'est vrai que
si megan elle serait restée là avant
peut-être qu'ils seraient tournées des
voyous je sais pas ce qu'ils sont
devenus tels qu'ils auraient pas de
travail qui je me suis dit bon bah
peut-être que là bas via les lieux qu'on
s'en sortirait mieux c'est vrai je suis
bien ici
je
j'ai vu des corps ont les mines la
banlieue tout ça c'est vrai qu'on vit
mieux par ici que là-bas
enfin moi mon point de vue à moi moi je
suis contente d'être ici et là je ne
partirai pas
la petite dernière se prénomme audrey
elle est née ici dans le limousin là
aussi la graisse de monsieur le maire a
réussi
vous êtes en train de lire la fiche son
village bourg des villes mais qui est
vraiment originaire du village de la
porcherie ce qui me tente pas du village
levé vous pour voir un petit peu
que doit-il y avoir pour vous dans un
village bout du bout des maisons les
maisons et des fermes du motionnaire une
école une école il ya autre chose
obligatoirement dans un village une
église une église est encore autre chose
il ya ils'agit d'hyères guillaume et il
ya dix ans à des arbres il peut y en
avoir
même s'il n'ya pas de village alors vous
lirez cette fiche pour la prochaine
foire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
laissez passer les enfants du pas de
calais et les autres aussi
depuis quelques mois il ya deux enfants
turcs à l'épaule il sain et athis leur
père originaire d'un atelier est
bûcheron dans l'isère
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]